premier dopage et j'envisage pas ah bon
vous droguez pas vous non pour le moment
je fais comment moi c'est sûrement pas
comment les champions du monde sont
venus et m'ont s'entraînant et en
croyant en étant entouré par une bonne
pendant une bonne personne c'est beau
surtout à celle que je suis passionné
donc ouais ça s'applaudissent à champion
du monde et voilà
africell avant qu'ils aillent plus loin
dans la conversation
sache que tout ça est arbitré et lorsque
tu toucheras alors laura flessel le
voyant rouge ça ne ment comme il est
d'usagé en escrime
vas-y c'est normal vous ne veut doper
pas mais en mai 2002 lors de la coupe du
monde de malaga vous terminé deuxième et
donc vous subissez laura flessel à un
contrôle anti dopage tout à fait
classique
hélas est presque trois mois plus tard
donc en août 2002 vous apprenez pas par
la fédération d'ailleurs mais par le
journal l'équipe que votre contrôle
étaient positifs que s'est il passé
tout bêtement le kiné de l'équipe de
france il lui a remis une mallette
attendait ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas
assez de médecins à la fédération et que
certaines fois vous êtes accompagné par
les kinés part de s'entraîner et donc
voilà ce qui n'est le vote s'appelle
david soulié sa part mme hasina vais
plus en stock de de pastilles de sel et
de sucre classique et la pharmacie a
remplacé par des comprimés de coramine
glucose sans connaître le fait qu'alain
prydz moi ça m'a pris on n'a pas le
droit
tu peux aller pisser là
lui a remis en fait en me disant puisque
le kiné lui a certifié qu'ils partaient
avec une équipe de france donc il
fallait absolument qu'il fasse très
attention et ce fameux pharmaciens en
fait lui a donné de la cour annule bus
causant dix ans il n'y a pas de problème
voilà
sauf que dans l'accord amine bull cause
il ya du lycée thani de sans déconner
alors que l'attention de la juste devant
la cabine de glucose n'altère pas en
altère en rien la performance donc pas
du dopage
alors on peut dire donc c'est un petit
peu comme richard virenque laura flessel
ça a été un petit peu drogués à l'insu
de votre plein gré ils ont une façon en
faisant confiance à aux staffs médicaux
staff fédéral
mais dans ces cas là il ya aucun
problème j'ai un email pour dire qu'ils
abattent un faux contact dans le collier
il savait deux fois qu'elle est touché
et ça s'annule pas alors on rectifie de
nuit donc laura en septembre 2002 le
tribunal disciplinaire à lausanne vous
condamnent quand même à trois mois de
suspension ses colères oui mais ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que étant donné qu'on
a on a bien prouvé qu'il n'y avait
aucune amélioration de performance on
s'est vite rendu compte que c'est en
fait c'était juste une guéguerre entre 2
jeudi les deux fédérations puisque ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la france
n'a jamais été un peu je dirais jamais
le mouton de panurge de la fédération
internationale et donc à travers cette
histoire ils ont réglé leur compte la
seule chose que leur la balle c'était
moi avec pas le droit de vous ici on
s'entraîne moi je me lève je n'ai jamais
son contrôle judiciaire
c'est quoi la résidence surveillée non
absolument lui seul va comme très bien
et damien escrime bah oui c'est du beau
gosse comme ça qu'il a une touche jouée
tendance assure apparemment non le
problème pourrait tout à fait clair
c'est que cette histoire vous allez
perdre leur à flesselles vos sponsors
parce qu'il y avait dans votre contrat y
avait une clause anti dopage qui disait
si le rappeler celle est contrôlée
positive
le contrat du sponsor s'annulent
automatiquement
vous avez perdu vos sponsors et vous
aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup de mal à faire
face a besoin d'engagement financier il
ya neuf mois
ma fédération a crié haut et fort qu il
investit une erreur et qu'ils allaient
régler cette situation neuf mois après
on est encore à la case départ et
personnes personne ne bouge
peut-être que ce soit va retrouver un
sponsor c'est un laboratoire
pharmaceutique de ses côtes
non je dirais que c'est vrai que neuf
mois après ben on a envie de taper un
peu le point sur la table c'est à dire
que étant donné que moi j'ai été j'ai
subi à l'apn aujourd'hui il ya préjudice
financier et moral
1 juste un petit exemple il ya je
travaille avec des enfants et il ya deux
trois jours il ya un enfant qui me dit
mais vous savez en fait il s'est pas
rendu compte que c'était moi donc on a
parlé on a tiré ensemble et puis
finalement je crois c'est plus que trois
mois et à la fin de la séance j'ai ouï
mais il ya laura flessel qui devait
passer
et elle n'est pas venue à auch et oui et
donc je me suis rendu compte qu'il ne
savait pas que c'était moi j'écoute
j'écoute me dit oui c'est c'la noah qui
fait d'eux les scream qui est championne
olympique qui a eu qui est resté trois
mois en prison d'un collier rouge alors
la dette
j'ai dû aller potillon disant écoutez il
avait 8 9 et 10 mois et dix ans et
j'aurais dit écoutez il fallait
absolument fait régler la situation et
dire trois mois ferme c'est une sanction
on va pas en prison
et à chaque fois depuis neuf mois je
suis obligé de faire les écoles mais là
pas la parole va se diffuser dans la
france entière
peut-être que je n'ai plus à le redire
bon alors voilà donc la fédération
monsieur abric
le patron de la fédération promet de
vous aider laura flessel malheureusement
ça va pas très vite il ne fait pas
vraiment le ton monte et il a regretté
quand même parce que effectivement il a
quand même regretter sur la place
publique que vous dépensiez sans compter
il vous a accusé de faire de la
cavalerie
on va remplacer les choses dans leur
contexte sachant que l'escrimé est un
sport amateur que je suis obligé de
travailler
donc forcément il fallait que je trouve
quelque part une compensation douzy des
diolas l'état l'âge n'en vouliez d'avoir
des sponsors donc je suis arrivé à avoir
des sponsors une marque sur une
compagnie d'assurance que je ne cite pas
donc à ce jour j'ai perdu mes sponsors
le
je veux juste à mon dieu c'est tout mon
argent mais les sponsors sont partis il
ya eu préjudice qu'ils étaient chiffrées
ouais ça s'arrête là n'aura fait ça nous
avait assigné la fédération un peu à
contrecoeur hier quand même neuf points
qu'à l'histoire désolé mais enfin un nom
des jeux olympiques d'athènes ça ou
flinguer le moral d'être en conflit que
votre fédération ça va nous faire gagner
100 corps non si tout ça arrange bien
oui oui dites moi c'est pas denis qui
vous pousse un peu à faire tout ça non
non pas du tout en bas du tout non ni
denis saint denis entre ces jeunes
l'amour guy ya des ia dépend de votre
vie qui m'a pas demandé mon ami la
dernière fois que laura est venue elle
m'a dit y aller mieux qu'une médaille
olympique
ce serait d'avoir un bébé et depuis le
bébé est né se portent bien
voilà ce soir c'est denis qui garde le
bébé avec une seule et bien
nora regarder votre caméra et dit un mot
à pierre abric parce que peut-être que
ce soir même peut-être qu'on peut régler
le problème ce soir alors dit jeudi que
j'espère vraiment que kill kill qui
s'est rendu compte que ça fait neuf mois
y que ben c'est pas avec ce que lui nous
donne convient bien donc
donc voila quoi la nationalité et puis
voilà cette jeune femme voilà il est
évident qu'elle est sincère c'est que
tout en elle dit qu'elle a raison voilà
allé hier fais pas ton couillon flux la
paix pierre carrière j'ai vu des études